tible sur place plus d'infos sur le
www.cancer.ca région reunion.com vous
écoutez la première il est 18 heures
[Musique]
le journal présenté préparé par florent
marot bonsoir bonsoir dit bonsoir à tous
prudence chez les syndicats de la sdr
ils attendent de voir ce que va donner
la nomination du nouveau directeur
général délégué ça s'est passé cet après
midi il ne prend pas la place du
directeur actuel du moins pas pour
l'instant
les grévistes eux rencontrent en ce
moment andry chez le patron du cdc
habitat nous irons sur place dans ce
journal
cinq ans de prison avec sursis et
surtout une interdiction totale
d'exercer sa profession s et ska rock
qui cet après-midi le substitut du
procureur à l'encontre de tristan
carrera il a plongé il y a quatre ans au
large de grand bois avec deux femmes
elles n'ont pas survécu
réactions à suivre aujourd'hui c'était
la journée mondiale des donneurs de sang
l'occasion pour le ffs de remercier les
donneurs et les bénévoles
combien de poches de sang ont été
récoltés réponse dans un instant les
épreuves du bac démarre lundi nous avons
rendu une petite visite aux lycéens qui
révise et puis ne manquez pas après ce
journal culture première jean-paul mais
là tu parleras de danse de cinéma et
d'archéologie
rendez-vous à 18h15
il s'appelle jacques durand c'est le
nouveau directeur général délégué de la
haye si dr il a été nommé cet après midi
lors du conseil d'administration
alors il ne prend pas la place du
directeur actuel pas pour l'instant en
tout cas même si les grévistes demander
son départ
un des grévistes qui sont intervenus
pendant une demi heure pour réclamer de
meilleures conditions de travail
il rencontre en ce moment andré yché le
patron du cdc habitat principal
actionnaire privé assure place mélodies
nourrit alors mélodies qui est ce
jacques durand ce nouveau venu à la sidr
prévu à l'ordre du jour c'était même le
numéro 8 peut-être précise mais bon
étant donné que cette mi temps cette
nomination par vaux intervient hasard du
calendrier au moment même où les
tensions sont alain à leur paroxysme
alex hyder on peut légitimement penser
que la direction ait de la st denis et
de la cdc habitat ont senti les choses
venir et ont préféré commencer à prendre
les devants aide peut-être cette volonté
de dialogue affichée du président du
directeur de la cdc habitat andré et
chez alors ce gène durant vient donc
remplacer l'actuel directeur général
adjoint qui va démissionner de ses
fonctions à la fin du mois pour cause
d'incompatibilité d'humeur avec le
directeur général de la sdr bernard
fontaine alors pour l'instant c'est vous
l'avez dit un des délégués syndicaux
sont en réunion avec ambre et essaie
depuis 17h15 c'est seulement à l'issue
de cette rencontre que l'on saura quelle
suite sera donnée au mouvement de grève
les manifestants eux sont en tout cas
plus déterminé que jamais un mélodies
nourrit en direct du siège de la haye si
dr à saint denis
en attendant la fin de la réunion et
d'éventuelles décisions la grève à
continue plus de précisions dans nos
prochaines éditions
les grévistes de la sidèrent qui sont
allés devant la préfecture ce matin là
où se trouvait déjà une dizaine de
retraités avec banderoles et pancartes
ils voulaient dénoncer la politique
d'austérité du président macron ils
réclament l'annulation de la hausse de
la csg et la fin du gel des pensions
la réunion compte environ 122 mille
euros
arrêtés dont 86 milles du privé et
malgré tout ils sont peu nombreux à
avoir répondu à l'appel de la cgt et de
la fsu
pourtant la situation est préoccupante à
la réunion selon roger alagama de
l'union confédérale des retraités de la
cgtr cher tu as la réunion dans le 86
mille personnes milliardaire n'a pas
rentrer cinq fois sans minimum
vieillesse des ans et tous en dessous de
800 euros par mois
nana à 2 280 euros la retraite lui même
ils confondent pas se dire le pouvoir
d'achat aujourd'hui il n'y a pas d'
équilibre n'est monté des sages et le
retraité retrouve pas les à payer des
factures fait du mal reviennent pas le
déboursement de retraités l'année parmi
les plus pauvres
ben écoute et même bien chien on a
travaillé 40 des gens pour toucher 1 re
et 50% de retraite des misères et et
chez a toujours dit on n'arrive pas à
faire face et même personne seule votre
été même avec deux personnes
eh bien on a des difficultés jan 10 20
roger alagama de l'union confédérale des
retraités de la cgtr interrogé par un
jean paul mais là d' emmanuel macron qui
a injustement annoncé hier une réforme
des retraites en 2019
une loi sur la dépendance également un
système par répartition préserver et 30
euros de plus sur le minimum vieillesse
pas sûr que ça calme les retraités la
colère également des agriculteurs un
mois maintenant du début de la campagne
sucrière en cause un courrier de tereos
reçue par plusieurs planteurs et qui
laisse entendre que les contrôles seront
renforcés
une accusation de fraude à peine voilées
selon les planteurs du coup il demande
l'organisation d'une table ronde
cinq ans de prison avec sursis au lieu
d'un et surtout une interdiction totale
d'exercer sa profession et c'est ce qu'a
requis cet après-midi le substitut du
procureur à l'encontre de tristan
carrera le gérant du club plongé
australe été jugé aujourd'hui en appel
après une plongée mortel au large de
grand bois c'était il ya quatre ans le 9
juin 2014 deux femmes sont mortes ce
soir là les familles des victimes
devront attendre le 6 septembre pour
connaître le délibéré
les parents de solenn une des victimes
avaient fait le déplacement depuis
l'hexagone son père à didier bernaches
assolant accepté témoigné responsabilité
elle est claire
elle est multiple les due à un
enchaînement de plein de petites causes
mais la première principale c'est de
permettre une sortie un jour où
normalement ne devait pas sortir
vous avez dit que au départ vous
souhaitiez pas vous constituer partie
civile
qu'est ce qui vous a décidé à ce qui
nous a décidés je les dis clairement et
c'est la réalité c'est d'avoir croisé le
responsable de la plongée monsieur
carrera 2 fois à la plage de
l'etang-salé le soir et puis une fois
pour s'expliquer et nous n'avons jamais
qu un mot de remords pour le décès de
notre fille que portant il connaissait
donc pas de nombreux morts pas
d'empathie pour nous c'était
insupportable
là didier bernaches assolant le père
d'une des victimes au micro la première
d' antoine garnier attristant carrera
risque donc une interdiction définitive
d'exercer il avait pris deux ans
d'interdiction uniquement en première
instance
la première 18h07 aujourd'hui florence
était la journée mondiale des donneurs
de sang
et oui et comme chaque année c'est
l'occasion pour le ffs de remercier les
donneurs et les bénévoles l'occasion
aussi d'organiser une grande collecte
festive au parc des expositions de saint
denis festive parce qu'il y avait des
massages des soins énergisants des
animations également tout en tout cas
pour attirer les donneurs alors est-ce
que ça a marché
nous allons poser la question à nathalie
grondin responsable communication à le
fs bonsoir bonsoir
alors est-ce que la journée a été bonne
un franc succès et on remercie toutes
les personnes qui se sont mobilisées 630
personnes sont venues donner leur faim
aujourd'hui on a pu collecter 450 poche
cents de plus que ce qui était visé à la
à l'origine donc c'est merci on a pas
d'autres mots on a vu 109 nouvelles
personnes venir faire ce geste citoyen
en ce 14 juin donc voilà grande réussite
on remercie les donneurs les partenaires
et les bénévoles qui nous ont aidés une
réussite qui comble un peu le déficit
tout à fait une réussite qui permet de
passer plus sereinement le cap de début
juillet on attend une baisse de la
fréquentation des collectes avec
l'arrivée des vacances scolaires c'est
quelque chose qu'on essaie d'anticiper
mais malheureusement la demande elle
reste soutenue on est à + 8 % depuis le
début de l'année donc cette collecte
l'équivalent de quasiment une semaine de
prélèvement donc vous voyez c'est pour
dire c'est l'équivalent de quasiment 8
collectes mobiles
ça nous permet de remonter un niveau un
peu plus sécuritaires en termes de
stocks et et ça c'est une très bonne
chose
merci beaucoup nathalie grondin rappelle
que vous êtes responsable communication
à le ffs santé toujours avec cette étude
qui va intéresser les malades qui ont
abandonné la nouvelle formule du
levothyrox elle a été analysée encore
une fois et france info révèle
aujourd'hui les conclusions de cette
étude il n'y avait pas de souci sur la
première version la deuxième formule en
revanche a provoqué chez des milliers de
malades à des effets secondaires la
molécule active était semble-t-il sous
dosés et il ya également la présence
d'une molécule pourtant retiré de la
vente aux états unis
c'est l'association française des
malades de la thyroïde qui a commandé
cette analyse cela fait un an qu'elle
demande des comptes aux laboratoires
merckx sahin présidente chantal lhoir
citoyen moyen ont pu payer ses analyses
et je vous explique pas le prix
l'ascension de l'état lit de laboratoire
mais nous sommes simplement des citoyens
engagés dans ma vie pour les autres les
trois loups qui ont été un allié
c'est un havre il ya trois millions et
demi qui était vendu à l'époque par mois
3 nous c'est à dire quoi faire on a tiré
le gros lot donc là je pense que parce
qu'on ne risque dans un pays qui se
distancie qui a eu un passé c'est pas
digne scary cela et c'est un nom qu'on
se bat il ya des souffrances et j'ai
fait et nous réclamons en urgence une
reconnaissance de crises sanitaires et
par principe de précaution carrément le
retrait du livre tire offre et la
demande vraiment un esprit de confiance
le respect de l'humain
chantal lhoir que demandez-vous
précisément aujourd'hui à la ministre le
tennis youn et chantal lhoir présidente
de l'association française des malades
de la thyroïde
on revient à la réunion pour parler du
bac
les épreuves débutent lundi à la tension
monte chez les candidats c'est l'heure
des dernières révisions au lycée
professionnel saint françois xavier
établissements des apprentis d'auteuil
océan indien
treize élèves préparent le bac pro
technicien d'études en bâtiment option
assistant architectes johann à damas doa
ci a rencontré à trois de ces lycéens
qui bénéficient de séances de révision
au sein de leur internat c'est depuis
fermé qu'alexandre erwan et vincent
vraiment démarrer des révisions du bac
si le déclic a été tardif la motivation
était néanmoins au rendez vous du coup
ils n'ont pas refusé l'aide de leur
professeur nathalie danville pour l'oral
d'anglais
aujourd'hui cette épreuve est passée
vincent est soulagé en anglais dans
l'ensemble ça va c'était très compliqué
mais c'est passé mais le gène
cafriplainois angoisse déjà pour les
prochaines épreuves
stressé pour le premier jour parce que
c'est froid ces histoires ce que je
pense galéré le plus mais le reste dans
l'ensemble je pense pas sortir pour
alexandre et à roanne s'est en revanche
les épreuves professionnelles qui pose
problème
alexandre nous avons les calculs après
il faut qu'on fait les plantureux
informatique il ya photoshop aussi du
bing vision et tous ces complexes en
fait
erwan lui craint le stress sur les
épreuves je peux du d'avoir perdu du
temps sur quelques logiciels mais après
dans l'ensemble je pense que je pourrais
réussir un stress qu'ils apprennent à
gérer tous les soirs lors des cours de
soutien à l'internât etc deux à trois
heures de travail sont devenues
indispensables vincent je pense que ce
n'est pas le soutien de moi même
j'aurais pas révisé il faut dire que le
travail de nathalie danville et
personnalisés on cible vraiment les
points qui n'ont pas été acquis pas
compris sur les matières où ils ont plus
de difficultés en tout cas aujourd'hui
et roanne vincent et alexandre ont à
coeur de réussir leur examen d'un
reportage johan à d'amadora si les
amoureux de football seront devant leur
télé ce soir pour le début de la coupe
du monde match d'ouverture russie arabie
saoudite à 19h noter que les trois
premiers matches de l'équipe de france
elles seront diffusées en direct sur la
première radio et si vous n'aimez pas le
foot deux solutions une virée au volcan
c'est le retour à la phase vigilance au
piton de la fournaise
les randonneurs peuvent à nouveau
descendre dans l'enclos mais seulement
sur les itinéraires balisés le dernier
koné rupture a lui été baptisé il
s'appelle python jasmin deuxième
solution si vous n'aimez pas le foot
le surf la pratique des activités
nautiques est de nouveau autorisée à
boucan canot et roches noires c'était
déjà le cas sur les spots de petit
boucan de l'ermitage des aigrettes et
des brisants une autorisation à titre
expérimental pour les membres du pôle
espoir de la ligue de surf
les activités ne peuvent se dérouler que
de 9 à 15 heures c'est la fin de ce
journal dans un instant culture première
jean-paul mais là tu parleras de danse
de cinéma et d'archéologie l'info
revient à 19h en télé dès 5h demain
matin en radio
[Musique]
je suis pas
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
demain
je suis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous écoutez la première idée de 18h15
[Musique]
bonsoir vendredi samedi dimanche a lieu
la 9e édition des journées nationales de
l'archéologie avec des conférences sur
les dernières fouilles préventives à la
réunion et la possibilité pour le public
de visiter des sites dire génie mode
conservatrice régionale nous en dit plus
des petits qui dansent pour la fin de
l'année scolaire dans le cadre de l'usep
cela se passe au théâtre de saint-gilles
samedi 550 marmaille vont se succéder
sur la grande scène saint gilloise
comment prépare-t-on une telle
manifestation réponse de betty la one
semble le cil en avant première ce soir
dans culture première avec armand
dauphin de chercheurs de pépites bien
nous parler de sa semaine musicale et à
ses côtés julie furie tiki dans une
plate forme vidéo de l'océan indien pelé
quoi film et gaël nous parlera surtout
de botaneco evolution dans quelques
secondes
la réalisation de cette émission est
signée jacques locat ma culture première
jean-paul belhade galles bonsoir alors
vos idées de sorties pour cette semaine
alors cette semaine ma chronique parle
de plantes plantes vers plantes
cultivées plantes sauvages
j'en parle parce que je les adore et
parce qu'à saint denis ça tombe bien
tiens il y à une galerie d'art qui
présente une magnifique petite
exposition sur les plantes alors l'expo
s'appelle bogdani comme révolution comme
vous l'avez fort bien dit révolution
botanique in french
et elle rassemble dix neuf artistes pays
en fait on leur a donné une consigne
dessine moi non pas un mouton mais une
plante no19 antastique sont allés
s'arracher les cheveux j'imagine mais au
bout de quelques mois
ils ont rendu leur copie c'est à dire
chacun deux ou trois oeuvres qui forment
donc cette expo lisbonne quoi et bien
c'est frappant de voir à quel point ces
artistes n'ont pas du tout mais alors là
pas du tout la même manière de
représenter les plantes
grosso modo c'est dix neuf artistes pour
60 nuances de plantes déjà comme ce sont
des individus différents
on a des oeuvres différentes et inégale
faut l'avouer certains ont fait des
photos de plantes couleur ou noir et
blanc argentique ou numérique
d'autres artistes ont fait des
sculptures de plantes ou bien encore une
vidéo ou des peintures ou des dessins ou
encore de la céramique surtout comme je
le disais chacun a sa vision de la
botanique
ce qui fait que l'on voit différentes
choses des forêts et des champs de canne
dessin de robes à fleurs c'est assez
surprenant il ya des artistes pour
qu'ils plantent rime avec flore
tropicale
ils ont donc représenté des hibiscus des
anthuriums une liane orchidées à
légiférer auditeurs et vous verrez par
exemple une roses de porcelaine de
françois-louis athénas c'est sobre mais
d'une élégance à tomber ce qui est
étonnant aussi c'est que les artistes ne
sont pas du tout sur le même registre je
m'explique il y en a qui sont sur le
registre de l'enfantillage et de la
dérision
tandis que d'autres ont produit un
travail nettement plus sérieux en tout
cas chers auditeurs
ça reste une visite agréable de aller 20
25 minutes pour redécouvrir la plante de
la racine aux fleurs et ça se passe
hunger galerie terlat dans le quartier
du bas de la rivière ils ne sont pas du
tout dans le côté élitiste de l'art
c'est pour ça qu'ils se sont installés
dans ce quartier populaire délibérément
j'ai rencontré une équipe généreuse
simple et très disponible
d'ailleurs demain le teint trop chimique
à d et après demain
françois-louis athéna seront dans la
galerie pour rencontrer ceux qui le
veulent bottone encore l'ufologie
exposition galerie terne à saint denis
jusqu'au 30 juin 2018 et un autre arrêt
dans un quartier de saint tenir prêts
vandales alors pour ceux qui n'ont pas
du tout la fibre végétale
il y à l'expo de la plasticienne
gabrielle manglou quartier champfleury
ça ne s'invente pas en fait gabriel est
parti d'une question mais où sont les
objets qui symbolisent les débuts du
peuplement de la réunion et notre
histoire et elle a eu une intuition
c'est que l'archéologie n'a pas encore
exhumé tous ces objets par conséquent au
moyen de photos dessins installations
entre autres elle a voulu présenter des
objets représentatifs de la société
créole son expo ses hypothèses de
l'objet en creux sis à la cité des arts
jusqu'au 30 juin et aux archives
départementales
jusqu'au 20 juillet leur single
culture première manceau virginie motte
vous êtes conservatrice régional
d'archéologie avec terry cornac vous
exposerai demain à 19 heures à l'hôtel
de ville de saint denis pour le
fonctionnement de l'archéologie
préventive et vous ferez le bilan des
opérations menées à saint denis
c'est quoi l'archéologie préventive
d'abord peut-être l'archéologie tout
court ou alors que j'ai tout court c'est
le chapeau une machin le soleil tout ça
non
l'archéologie est une discipline qui a
encadré par la loi et l service de
l'archéologie de l'adac aussi veille à
l'application de cette législation sous
l'autorité du préfet de région et en
france il y a deux types d'archéologie
l'archéologie programme et qui est lié
uniquement à des objectifs de recherche
scientifique et l'archéologie préventive
qui est lié à l'aménagement du
territoire
alors c'est ce que vous faites vous cela
nous on coordonne l'ensemble de
l'activité archéologique et donc on a
prescrit depuis la création du service
régional de l'archéologie en 2010 68
opération 30 opérations dans le champ du
programme et et 38 opérations dans le
champ du préventif
alors c'est quoi le préventif et le
préventif à la réunion d'abord la
première phase c'est la phase de
diagnostic
on a prescrit 30 opérations de
diagnostic sur tout le territoire de la
réunion
le diagnostic vise à avoir si un terrain
concerné par un aménagement est
susceptible de mettre au jour des
vestiges archéologiques la phase de
diagnostic permet de voir si on a des
vestiges dans quel état de conservation
ils sont seal s'il nécessite une seconde
phase d'archéologie préventive qu'on
appelle la fouille et donc on a prescrit
déjà huit fouilles à la réunion donc
deux ont été déjà amené sur le terrain
la première ces grands enfants à saint
paul en 2014 et la deuxième fouille
c'était la fruit de saint pol roux des
premiers français qui a été fait sur le
terrain au premier trimestre de cette
année 2010 alors vous étiez devant la
préfecture j'ai vu monsieur cornec donc
du coup tu en fasses du rallye vous avez
avait fouillé là il a fouillé à cet
endroit on a trouvé des marines
c'est bien cela mais on a tout recouvert
mais quel est l'intérêt
l'archéologie préventive est une heure
et une discipline citoyenne
l'archéologie préventive concerne en
effet chaque aménageurs chaque élu
chaque citoyen la loi prévoit à
l'intervention des archéologues en
préalable aux chantiers d'aménagement
l'aménagement du territoire ne se fait
plus au détriment des vestiges du passé
mais permet au contraire leur étude
approfondie et donc quand les
archéologues quitte un terrain celui ci
est rendu à l'aménagement
on ne peut pas sauvegarder tous les
vestiges il faut concilier la médiation
du territoire et la sauvegarde par
l'étude de ces vestiges mais pour neo
les travaux dont vous faites référence
était la première phase une
d'archéologie préventive c'est à dire le
diagnostic mais une seconde phase
d'archéologie préventive sur les
vestiges les plus conséquents qui ont
été mis au jour notamment sur la place
charles de gaulle vont faire l'objet
d'une fouille a reculé qu'elle en ait au
moins préciser ces nouvelles entrées
ouest oui d'accord alors ça alors on
jamais si vous trouvez quelque chose de
vraiment majeur un important vous allez
l'exhumer de mettre au jour pour qu'on
puisse le voir ou alors jamais à cause
de l'aménagement du territoire mais moi
j'étais frustré je vous dis tout de
suite un bon voilà c'est pourtant que je
pose cette question là en fait
l'archéologie préventive c'est de la
sauvegarde par l'étude point final
voilà un archéologue se documente bien
évidemment en amont de la fouille il
rassemble l'ensemble des sources écrites
des documents iconographiques
ensuite il procède à des travaux terrain
donc des sondages des fouilles
il va analyser et interpréter les
vestiges qui ont été mis au jour il va
les étudier en laboratoire il va
consigner l'ensemble de ces documents
dans un rapport scientifique mais son
travail ne s'arrête pas là puisque une
grande part de son travail et de
restituer les résultats de ces
opérations au public et c'est pour ça
que nous menons et que nous nous
inscrivons dans c'est une 9e journées
nationales de l'archéologie
donc ces journées il y aura
une quelque chose qui m'a interrogé
quand j'ai lu le papier on m'avait
envoyé il ya les perles de mayotte qu'on
a découverte qui daterait de plus de
mille ans c'est cela oui alors on a fait
un atelier spécifique pour les enfants
en fait un pour les perles de mayotte on
a conçu une mallette pédagogique
la mallette est conçu pour raconter aux
enfants que grâce aux fouilles
archéologiques à mayotte on a mis au
jour des milliers de perles qui datent
de la période médiévale et ses perles
sont des vestiges de parures de collier
de ceinture de pagnes elles proviennent
partout d'asie d'inde d'afrique du monde
arabe et l'atelier permet aux enfants de
s'approprier ces découvertes
scientifiques majeures qui renseigne
tout le commerce de l'océan indien et de
toucher du doigt ses lointains ancêtres
en imaginant des parures et surtout
imaginer ce qui aurait pu les porter à
je me faire l'avocat du temps pour que
vous exposez à la réunion et à mayotte
elle a fait aussi à mayotte bien sûr ces
terminaux dans le cadre des journées
nationales de l'archéologie
pourquoi cette année vous ne les aimez
de les exploser pas mayotte house est
coincé là là vous êtes coincés là vous
avez le trou noir bon en fait bref
s'effacer pas qu'à la réunion est pas
mal alors on va parler aussi de la paléo
forêt de la rivière des galets qu'est ce
que c'est que la pâle et aux forêts de
la rivière des galets ça situe
exactement au bar au milieu à cannes en
droit d'attendre des mois ont regardé
par votre papier vous connaissez parce
qu'ils ont des trucs là vous êtes en
train de vous affoler alors c'est quoi
ça sequana paléo forêt mais c'est les
vestiges de la forêt primaire débat de
l'ouest de la réunion cdd bois organique
qui avait été mis au jour à l'occasion
de crue exceptionnelle et qui a fait
l'objet d'une opération en botanique qui
a été menée sur le terrain en 2013 avec
la ddt accueilli le muséum le parc
national et le nf et
ces sept on a fait des prélèvements sur
ces bois organique et on a pu les dater
de plus de 1500 ans et donc plus de
mille ans avant l'arrivée des humains
qu'est-ce qui nous raconte il peut
raconter c'est bon en dehors de la
datation et on vous en donner des
indices je sais pas sur la façon dont le
terrain était à cette époque là je sais
pas s'il y avait des gens des choses
comme ça dont on ne sait pas où j'en
serai peut-être des australopithèques
nord les personnes justement le
témoignage d'une forêt primaire de la
réunion vient donc il y avait pas
d'ossements de d'oiseaux jak2 deux
doigts pour cette opération
pas du tout rien du tout alors qu'est-ce
que les gens décident que les gens
pourront visiter pendant ces trois
joueurs quels sont ces sites et vous
alors trois villes se sont associés
sainte rose saint paul jean paul et
saint denis alors pour saint denis il y
a deux gros rendez-vous déjà demain soir
vous causez mairie à 19 heures moi je
vais présenter l'ensemble des activités
du service régional de l'archéologie à
la réunion à mayotte aussi puisque vous
parliez tout à l'heure de manière sensée
on et voilà par convention on travaille
aussi à mayotte est aussi dans le
territoire des terres australes et
antarctiques françaises
moi je vais présenter l ensemble des
activités du service et tiré kordek qui
est le référent océan indien de l'inrap
l'institut national de recherches
archéologiques préventives va faire le
point de toutes les avancées sur toutes
les opérations qui ont été conduites
spécifiquement à saint denis
ça c'est demain soir à 19h à l'hôtel de
ville est un grand rendez vous pour les
familles samedi à 16 de 9 heures à 17
heures au parc de la providence alors
c'est gratuit on attend beaucoup de
monde puisque on a
a voulu faire un véritable village
archéologique avec plusieurs stands en
vous parliez de la mallette des perles
de l'océan indien de la mallette pas
liées aux forêts puisqu'on a fait une
mallette pédagogique aussi pour
renseigner les enfants de toutes ces
découvertes botaniques qui ont été
faites à l'occasion de cette opération
botanique en 2013 mais il y aura aussi
un atelier botanique l'âme avec fanny
qui est qui vient d'être diplômée en
paléoenvironnements et qui va nous
expliquer comment on mène des analyses
scientifiques sur ces macro est végétaux
elle va apprendre à tamiser à identifier
les graines champollion voilà à déduire
les informations sur le paysage
ensuite on a deux deux expositions la
l'exposition archéologie australe ans
c'est la première fois qu'on va la
déployer sur l'île de la réunion et on a
30 bages qui est qui renseigne sur 30
belle opération de la réunion
archélogique et puis une version allégée
de l'exposition tromelin cette belle
exposition qui avait déployé voilà la
stella matutina pour ceux qui ne
l'auraient pas vu on a la version
allégée allégée de de l'exposition et
ensuite on aura les archéologues qui
seront là pour informer le public sur
les méthodes de l'archéologie et les
houthis qui fait le travail de
l'archéologue de son activité de terrain
jusqu'au laboratoire
et puis on aura aussi pour la première
fois l'ouverture du centre de
conservation et d'études du mobilier de
la réunion c'est un un précieux outil
pour nom puisque l'état a le devoir de
conserver
de la meilleure manière possible le
mobilier archéologique qui provient des
fruits de la réunion
est ce cette cet outil est normalement
réservé aux professionnels aux ans et
enfin aux étudiants parfois aux
restaurateurs puisque l'année dernière
on a eu un restaurateur qui est venu
travailler pour restaurer du mobilier de
la réunion et de mayotte mais aussi vous
parliez de gabrielle manglou elle est
venue et elle c'est la nourrit son
travail d'artiste si en venant au centre
de conservation et d'études pour voir
une ou deux mots qu'est ce que vous
entendez par mobilier alors le mobilier
de moins
voilà alors le mobilier c'est tout ce
qu'on tous les objets manufacturés qu'on
peut trouver dans les fouilles dakhla ok
ça je voulais savoir ce que vous oubliez
bon ça ça fait mais bon sang on pense à
une un salon donc urgence que c'est le
mobilier sont des vestiges
archéologiques qui sont un patrimoine à
forte valeur scientifique
voilà sont pour nous nos archives les
archives papier aux archives
départementales c'est l'instrument de
travail des historiens nous nos archives
c les archives du sous sol et donc les
boules et le mobilier les biens
archéologiques mobilier sont nos
archives du social merci virginie motte
les journées nationales de l'archéologie
ces vendredi samedi et dimanche 1
culture première bonsoir arpents dauphin
island rileys tous surpris et vous êtes
un intrépide du cinéma à boulimique du
7ème art découvert pépite c'est vous qui
est à l'origine de la projection du
mafate et et de nuit de grève avant de
parler de la semaine du film musical
question la réaction du public
réunionnais la projection de ces deux
films la projection
les projections se sont bien passées on
doit bien public avait pas mal de
questions à poser sur la façon dont
c'est que les filles me certain qu'ils
trouvaient que dans la bataille avec la
poésie d'autres - enfin ils verront des
discussions très intéressantes et aussi
par rapport à yoann c'est eux a été
commandé à trois ils sont filmés cet
environnement bétonné de la banlieue
parisienne
par quoi on les avait trouvés ces de ces
deux réalisateurs alors le mafate et il
y avait eu cette année en début d'année
une avant-première à stella donc le
réateur y arrête m'a contacté et puis
j'avais été à l'avant première et
j'avais décidé de sortir son film
malheureusement c'était un film qui fait
que 53 minutes donc je trouvais ça un
petit peu compliqué de sortir un moyen
métrage en salles de 53 militent donc on
a cherché un court métrage à m en
complément se doit et des cars et ne
correspondait n'allait pas du tout enfin
pour moi en tout cas c'était des films
d'animation qui collait pas trop avec ce
qu'il avait fait sur le mafatais et un
jour il ya un lien de jean-charles que
je connaissais quand tu étais petit et
qui rêvait déjà de faire du cinéma qui
m'appellent pour me dire qu'il a fait
son premier long métrage et donc du
coupage et j'ai vu son film j'ai décidé
de mettre les deux films donc une hutte
gred et de mafate et les sortir ensemble
je trouve que vos deux fils mon intérêt
c'est certainement judicieux redis je
pense que je rentre dans quelques
instants
je sais pas où vous avez quantifier le
nombre de personnes qui sont venus
d'angers pas encore tandis que moi j'ai
un collègue qui me dit je suis allé on
était trois bagues en salle après c'est
vrai que il ya eu des séances n'y a pas
eu beaucoup de monde ces risques il ya
une concentration des spectateurs alors
je sais pas si c'était sur saint denis
ou sur saint pierre
en tout cas c'est vrai je pense que
c'est sans doute sa liste avec sursis on
reste concentrés principalement sur
trois jours avec le mercredi aux parents
- le jeudi non plus le vendre et non
plus après tout les jours viennent
surtout le week-end en fait vous avez la
foi
ouais j'ai la foi way
après la passion et j'y crois encore tu
as et bien il faut des gens quand je
pense que sinon cinéma amour est en tous
les cas le cinéma tel que vous le
concevez alors que la semaine du film
musical ça se passe donc à partir de
mercredi prochain au ritz à saint-denis
et au moulin kfor avait des cabris
pourquoi moulin à café
alors moi ça fait très longtemps que je
travaille avec la ville de saint pierre
et ça fait très longtemps qu'on est
ensemble des semaines thématiques fonds
corporate au rex pas parce que c'est la
ville de saint pierre qui soutient ces
semaines thématiques et c'est un travail
vraiment historique j'y serais tenté de
dire même en mémoire que les premiers
films en vo que j'ai montré à la réunion
josé montre à saint pierre bien d'autres
sujets non je suis dit je suis
international ou d'esquiver notre
question rap alors il ya plusieurs films
il y en a cinq juges étaient pas de
bêtises
voilà il ya cinq-six mookie dont de film
de carlos saura voilà tout à fait alors
il ya argentinas je fais mon intéressant
avec évidemment et puis encore deux
films
alors j'essaie de savoir un peu de quoi
de quoi ça parle je garde quand même
ou alors c'est le carrosse oreilles
quelqu'un qui adore qui adore la musique
du coup est donc là il avait déjà fait
des films sur le tango
oui la femme sur cinq avait été nommé
aux oscars donc là il a fait deux films
le premier c'est bien de flamenco qui
parle donc du flamenco donc on a on a
des ruines une classe en fait du cookie
qui apprend on qui prend des cours de
flamenco
on a aussi des figures de des très
belles figures de flamenco où on voit
effectivement ces hommes et ces femmes
en train de danser et on a des
témoignages de deux grandes de grandes
personnalités du flamenco
oui ensuite il a fait un autre qui ne
fait pas l'argentine aquila est une
sorte de road-movie un peu quand elle
fait wenders avec havana bonavista
social club c'est ça voilà est donc là
il a parcouru toute l'argentine pour
rencontrer des gens des musiciens mais
aussi des gens de la société civile pour
voir comment évolue et à la musique et
voir les différents courants ce que
c'est vrai que en plus nous on connaît
qu'un seul gros courant de manière
générale ce qu'est le tango on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya évidemment que
l'inde influence et donc valais fait ce
grand voyage à travers l'argentine alors
j'ai pas regardé le fus puisque
impossible de le trouver sur youtube
je n'ai vu que des bandes-annonces
voilée au cinéma
fausse aimable et est-ce qu'il va dans
la pampa oui bah il va voir les hommes
danser le tango aussi dans la pomme pas
il fait il ya vraiment un beau ouais
c'est vraiment on voit plein plein de
choses et le personnage qui
interviennent puis ce qui est bien aussi
c'est qu'on a aussi voilà des gens qui
qui nous parle aussi de la musique ce
que ça nous rapporte aussi au quotidien
et ça c'est aussi extrêmement intéressé
puis si je dis pas de bêtises il ya
quand même parmi les acteurs de noms
connus fin tous les cas il ya chico
buarque j'ai vu enfin d'aider des noms
comme ça au générique il ya quelques
quelques noms connus élargir et je les
connais pas tous je suis pas un grand
lemps un grand spécialiste de la musique
ménard général mais c'est vrai qu'il ya
quelques noms quelques noms connus alors
il ya un autre film aussi l'appareil
j'ai pas pu le voir mais je suppose
facile j'avais quand même une espèce de
petit documentaire c'est l'opéra de jean
stéphane bron je ne connais pas de
réalisateur ne le représentait alors
jean stéphane bron a fait plusieurs
documentaires il y en avait 40 états
unis qui s'appelle le
wall street contre une université parce
que universités qui se révolter contre
wall street
là du coup dépasser à l'opéra paris
bastille il a passé un an et demi donc
il affirmé tout ce qui est dans l'opéra
donc pas uniquement les artistes mais on
voit aussi au niveau administratif
comment ça se déroule on côtoie aussi
les techniciens avec les difficultés
qu'ils rencontrent aussi les avantages
qu'ils on est dans une structure aussi
aussi importants dont les collisions va
les coulisses on voit les coulisses on a
des couturières on a aussi on voit aussi
bien mon amant il ya françois hollande
qui doit venir à l'opéra donc on voit
aussi quand tous ortement s'agite
voilà on a aussi les voilà le cet énorme
bâtiment quand il s'intègre dans ce dans
ce quartier parce que ça qu'ils disent
est immense sur cette carte et puis on a
aussi voilà comment ça comment la vie se
passe après le après l'attentât du 13
novembre
et comment voilà on a vraiment une un
documentaire qui est extrêmement complet
sur se ruent sur l'opéra on a aussi une
petite école en zone d'éducation
prioritaire et qui prépare un spectacle
avec des allées des intervenants donc on
a aussi ce côté un peu un peu rêve où on
se dit voilà cette petite cette petite
led cette petite école voilà c'est
magique pour eux de se retrouver dans ce
bâtiment absolument ballet garnier alors
ce qui est étonnant quand même c'est que
jean stéphane bron n'est absolument pas
un fan d'opéra india moi je connais pas
du tout les périodes je passais pas mon
truc mais j'ai vous quand même voulu
connaître savoir ce que c'était après je
crois qu'on peut faire des signes serait
forcément spécialistes sur un sujet
après ça c'était un documentaire il a
fait sur l'opéra ils rêvent certainement
plus faire aussi sur sur l'elysée ou sur
mesure je sais pas quoi sur mac rompre
peut-être et donc là d'un coup de coeur
est un cinéaste qui pratiquent déjà son
métier c'est d'être in à ce documentaire
est donc là il nous fait découvrir et
certainement aussi avec ses yeux de
novices cette grande machine qu'est
l'opéra et ont découvert un endroit qu
absolument fabuleux que peu de gens
connaissent une carrière de film qui
sans intérêt très intéressant à mon avis
celui d'alexandre messina et de bayonne
à najaf
najafi c'est bien ça c'est percu jeunes
alors peur que j'aime ce sont des
autistes des artistes autistes
voilà c'est ça donc c'est un un
documentaire en fait voilà sur des
groupes de musique qui composent l
autiste donc il ya aussi leurs
éducateurs qui sont là donc ils sont
dans un dans un lieu en métropole dont
j'ai oublié le nom donc ils se disent
qu'ils sont là donc avec ils font de la
musique il ya des électeurs qui sont
évidemment aussi des musiciens est donc
là l'objectif c'est donc ça fait une
dizaine d'années qu'ils ont formé un
groupe qui ils ont déjà fait aussi
l'olympia entre autres et donc cette
particularité c'est que bon ben voilà ce
sont effectivement des autistes ceci
étant le récepteur a pas voulu faire un
film spécifiquement sur les autistes les
remises et musicale oui et plutôt
musicale de haut rang juste la barre 210
juste au début je suis autistes points
en quatre vingts on plante le décor et
puis après on voit de la musique voilà
on a effectivement les concerts mais on
a aussi toute la préparation
la préparation des concerts quand on l'y
voit aussi en train de décrire comment
se passe ce processus d'écriture
on voit aussi une angoisse de l'artiste
voilà tout à fait on y voit aussi
d'entendre dans ce centre où ils sont
comme tout le monde avec eux leur
histoire d'amour leurs preuves lors de
leurs différents problèmes et il restera
vraiment bien non c'est vrai que c'est
pas sûr sur des autistes comme il le dit
d'ailleurs qui kiffent un groupe de
musique ce moment sur des musiciens qui
ont effectivement qu'il ya une
différence qui ont une différence alors
nolens sans ça se passe en iran alors
nolan sanguin se passe effectivement en
iran et là c'est donc l'histoire d'une
femme qui veut monter un concert donc le
problème c'est qu'en iran alors les
femmes ne peuvent pas faire un concert
seul devant un public mixte
elles peuvent faire et peuvent se
produire mais il faut qu'ils aient un
homme sûr sur la scène donc là on a une
donc une jeune femme qui s'appelle sarah
qui décident de monter un concert
donc elle se bat avec les autorités
politiques donc voilà que ça va aussi
avec eux avec les représentants
religieux
donc il ya un moment donc bon ça bloque
elle décide de faire venir des
musiciennes de france ça bloque aussi un
moment ça bloque aussi voilà malgré tout
elles continuent elles se elle se bat
après donc au losc a aussi intéressant
c'est qu'on est quand même aussi dans
des relations tout une espèce
d'hypocrisie aussi avec effectivement
des représentants de l'état qui dise pas
oui mais qui disent pas non
la voix de la femme et sexuelle rien qui
disent à la voix de la femme sur un truc
comme ça en voulant dire voilà il va me
faire chavirer donc c'est pas parce
qu'elle chante quoi voilà tout à fait
bien apprécié que le voilà ce qu'elle
dit est aussi un moment sarah c'est que
là il faut absolument faire ce concert
faut absolument que les femmes puissent
chanter parce que sinon un jour les voix
des femmes pour s'éteindre en iran et ce
qui est paradoxal c'est que les femmes
peuvent prendre des cours de chant elle
peut prendre des cours de musique mais
qu'après je vois finale toute une série
d'interdits qui lui aurait donné que
vous ils ne peuvent pas exprimer
exprimer leur art et donc voilà donc
cette femme se bat et puisque c'est
intéressant c'est qu'on est aussi après
à partir - les français qui arrivent en
iran on a aussi tout le côté
diplomatique qui joue qui se joue ou
deux sur la période où l'iran est aussi
avec eux avec les premiers pneumatiques
sur le nucléaire
et tout d'un coup on a aussi donc des
comportements qui changent et on voit
que finalement ce concert prend des
proportions politique et qui sont qui
sont énormes et qui voilà qui les
pousseront dans le bon sens jusqu'à
quand ce sont diffusés enfin diffuser
projeter les films alors les cimes son
projet d'enquêté d'une semaine
thématique qui a lieu du 20 au 26 juin
au rite hassani et au moins la caf et la
ravine des cabris
alors vous avez en face de vous je jeudi
fioretti bonsoir joly qui n'a été une de
nos consoeurs elle se lance dans la
création de la première plateforme vidéo
de l'océan indien à un collègue m'a dit
lundi en océanie oui oui pourquoi pas
oui bah le sang est un diable
la communauté de l'anneau c'est alors le
nom donc de cette plate forme c koi film
quoi filmer une affaire tricéphale
alors qui vous accompagnent alors audrey
bacall trouvé ça fait trop voilà donc
effectivement on est les trois à l'e3
porteuse du projet aqua film projet coup
sur lequel on travaille depuis plus d'un
an et demi est qui et qui s'apprête elle
à être lancée d'ici le mois d'août fin
d'ici la rentrée du mois d'août aurait
ensuite du crowdfunding dans un instant
mais alors comment comment comment vous
allez faire pour attirer le chaland en
admettant que vous ayez d'argent avec le
film bien sûr mais facile à dire ça
monte
il faudra un blog il faut de la
publicité photos bonnes choses
exactement ce que vous allez faire
alors effectivement indomptables tout
d'abord dont ont rejoint ce sera aussi
d'abord sur la qualité des films
jusqu'en je tiens quand même à le
préciser est effectivement pour attirer
un public sur notre plateforme on a
prévu de monter un blog un blog
d'actualité où on relaiera un certain
nombre de choses sur l'actualité du
cinéma mais sur notre plateforme aussi
ce qu'on veut en fait c'est d'abord on
aura une quarantaine entre une
quarantaine une cinquantaine de films
sur la plateforme avait déjà retrouvé
on est en train de constituer notre
catalogue en ce moment et on a et on
avance bien et il est clair qu'on aura
nos notre catalogue de prêt pour la
rentrée en août
vous avez
un conseiller en face du tout à fait on
doit d'ailleurs ravi de voir
merci beaucoup et en fait sur cette donc
l'idée c'est vraiment de partir sur un
petit catalogue pour pouvoir bien
communiquer sur ses films et que ses
films trouvent leur public
parce qu'évidemment il y aura des choses
très très différentes sur cette
plateforme y aura des courts métrages
des longs métrages du documentaire de
l'animation dans des genres très
différents qui peuvent être des choses
très engagé très décalé des choses très
bien d'avoir doit alors ou alors voilà
des histoires ou des histoires
universelles et donc je pense qu'on
pourra toucher un public assez différent
selon de programmation et pour ça aussi
ce qu'on veut faire c'est de mettre des
thématiques en place on mettra quatre
cinq films en avant deux pays différents
de formats différents qu'on qui
traiteront par contre eux d'une
thématique différente et avec ces
éléments là on espère en tout cas
pouvoir pouvoir intéresser il y aura des
films en version originale sous titrée
il y aura des films tous nos films sont
en version originale sous-titrée alors
sous titrée en français dans un premier
temps et dans un second temps quand les
moyens seront plus conséquents
on prévoit de de sous-titrés tous nos
films en anglais pour le public en golf
anglophone parce que l'afrique du sud se
représente avec complètement quand on
dit océan indien sur cinq fait quand on
dit océan indien on dit donc on dit la
réunion 10 madagascar ont dit maurice
mans si audi on dit aussi l'afrique du
sud et le mozambique et mayotte
l'australie est encore l'inde quand
quelques millions de personnes qui
regardent défiler oui tout à fait donc
oui le l'afrique du sud sera représentée
bien or vous avez parle donc du blog
comment comment je veux je peux faire
moi alors si je suis intéressé
on va faire comment pratiquement pour
pouvoir il faut s'abonner il faut
compter simplement alors en fait les
films seront pas ce qu'on peut son
propre schéma proposé de 3,3 façon
différente on pourra soit s'abonner soit
louer un film à la séance en soir on a
envie de regarder un film alors pas dans
le catalogue taxe film nous plaît on le
loue ou alors si vraiment on est fan et
qu'on a très envie de posséder ce film
ou de pouvoir le voir sans connexion
internet
on pourra acheter et télécharger
il touche heures alors les tarifs pour
l'instant ils sont pour ce qui est de
l'abonnement il sera 7 euros pour la
location ça va de 2 à 5 euros après
c'est des choses qui doivent se négocie
aussi avec les ayants droit ou en fait
tout dépendra de la longueur du film du
format enfin là c'est des choses qui
doivent se décider qui doivent se
décider rapidement
c'est déjà lui reste quatre jours pour
donc le parti de la participation au
show pas le mot le financement
participatif mais déjà 9651 euro ce soir
tout à fait donc il vous reste encore à
peu près 500 euros pour pouvoir arriver
à bord dix mille euros c'est déjà un
premier pas commence pour les euros les
500 euros en quatre jours oui je pense
que commencer voilà alors si vous avez
fait quoi alors si on a quinze mille
euros ce qui serait formidable
en tout cas si on a quinze mille euros
ce qui est sûr c'est que on aura la
possibilité de sous titrer elle a un
maximum de films en anglais donc d'avoir
un sous titrage et en français et en
anglais
et puis après c'est c'est d'aller vers
d'autres choses plus c'est d'avoir plus
de films vidéos contenus c'est d'avoir
enfin voila c'est se donner la
possibilité de valada les vraiment
pouvoir aller chercher plus de contenus
plus de films en tout cas c'est vraiment
ce qu'on rende enfin vous en pensez
priorité alors moi je sais c'est vrai
que je défends le avant tout le cinéma
en salle mais c'est vrai que cinéma il
est diffusion des films évolué je trouve
que ce que vous faites est absolument
formidable
c'est plein d'ambition et ça c'est
vraiment très bien et c'est vrai que
malheureusement les films sortent au
cinéma les films de la zone on a quand
même beaucoup de mal
allez voir est donc ce que vous faites
est absolument formidable je suis
convaincu je sors ans chez qui tout de
suite jean-paul encore s'il ya des gens
qui nous écoutent et qui sont intéressés
par pour participer au financement
il doit faire quoi alors il ya deux
solutions soit ils se rendent sur le
site internet ulule et il tape
coaticookois film dans le moteur de
recherche
car w4 lemay a exactement kwh ou alors
ils vont sur notre page facebook qui est
pareil il tape quoi film est sûre sur
cette page y trouveront tout un tas
d'informations sur toute la campagne
quand on a mené depuis depuis 24 jours
maintenant ils pourront découvrir une
partie de notre programmation déjà parce
qu'on a quand même annoncé certains
films et le gris alors on a annoncé
dernièrement on a annoncé est là le film
d'elza dahmani à l'éco qu on a un film
aussi qui s'appelle un documentaire qui
est une expédition qui s'appelle bartas
sur sur un groupe de high liner qui il
fonde la slackline mais sur une ligne
exactement
tout à fait on a annoncé aussi un film
enfin le film d'une jeune malgache
firoz à houssen modèle on a aussi le
film de vincent toirac since the unicorn
le film on avait cinq films qui étaient
cachées qui était réservé à nos
contributeurs donc les films de sa
michalak du graffiti dans les voiles par
exemple qui s'il y avait d'autres plans
s'arrête là ce fut enfin plusieurs que
je ne connaissais pas je vais pas vous
allez découvrir des pépites dont la
fille du roi film alors quoi filmer en
dehors du poivre
est ce qu'il ya un autre jeu de mots
intérieure n'ont pas fait baisser le
poids c'est le questionnement oui
d'accord mais en dehors de cela ça a une
connotation fin pour nous pendant
l'écriture
avec kwz scène je ne vous suis pas la
graphie créole aka double parlant car
deux êtres rapport non mais si en fait
dans leur toit dans la façon dont on l'a
écrit y avait tout à fait à cette idée
c'est ce que vous dormez la nuit de
repos en ce moment d'accord ok vous êtes
comme armand dauphin vous rêvez beaucoup
de films enfin fait son cinéma
avant on va vous dormez pour qu'on vous
rêvez de films venus non je rêve pas
forcément de sublimes et c'est vrai que
je suis quelqu'un qui rêve énormément
jeu j'ai tout le temps la tête dans les
étoiles à tête dans les étoiles j'ai
tout le temps à lantin ébullition en
train de penser à plein de choses je
vais demander à jacky revel de vous
inviter parce qu'il a la tête dans les
étoiles toutes et tous les dimanches
mais j'essaie de garder comme aussi un
peu les pieds sur terre avec le temps il
faut en tous les cas on rappelle donc
coiffe il me reste quatre jours pour
vous ayez dix mille euros c'est une
bulle d'autre qui ait fait ou facebook
ou facebook
voilà vous nous direz si vous êtes vous
avez réussi à bien sûr un plaisir bien
en fait une pause bébé du cadre une
petite minute et ensuite on va danser
[Musique]
m
bien donc voilà donc on attaque la fin
et 18h50 bonsoir betty là où ils sentent
que je retrouve mes papiers j'en ai
tellement partout que je me retrouve
tout ça bien
détendez-vous à je me sens très très
très très juste envers nous mêmes et
vous êtes ces votes que c'est votre
première votre première radio première
radio bien on va voir comment ça se
passe alors ils dansent ces petits
500-550 dans le cadre du 32e festival de
danse usep henry très bas lag et seront
à saint gély viennent de 20 écoles
différentes de toute l'île c'est qu'
henri très malade je peux faire à peu
près mais sur le net il n'y a rien
aujourd'hui c'est fort qui est il ce
monsieur alors donc plus plus
particulièrement lié à lui cep
il a été délégué usep et président du
comité départemental usep et décider il
est décédé à peu près une quinzaine
d'années et c'est à partir de là que le
festival porte son nom 1 2 puis l'a10
est telle depuis la 17ème édition
exactement on est on est à la 32e à
troyes 2e édition du festival qui et je
dirai le moment pour nous à l'usap de
clôturer l'année 8 cep par un bel
événement qui qui va regrouper tous les
enfants des associations usep d'école un
jeu précise ce sont des écoles qui sont
affiliées à l'usep pour être affilié à
l'usap il faut créer son association au
sein de l'école et ce sont des enfants
qui arrivent des quatre coins de l'île
on essaie d'avoir à peu près la même la
même proportion dans les zones u 7 faut
savoir qu'on en a 5 1 5 bassins usep le
nord le sud l'est l'ouest évidemment et
le centre et le nord-ouest à bon compte
pourquoi pas les eaux
mais les halls et oui il arrive dans
chacun des bassins de la mer jusqu'aux
montagnes bien alors qu dont vous avez
expliqué comment on pouvait être
adhérent mais je remarquais parce que
j'ai compté 1 il ya quand même ça
deniers et sa baignoire sont sur
représentés par rapport aux autres
ah oui et non j'ai compté 5 2004 le
tampon 4 saint benoît à troyes saint
paul 3 s'attendre et un san marina le
port st louis alors ah oui parce quand
on parle aux jeunes
on ne parle pas en commune attend donc
dans nos bassins usep
on est en cinq zones donc pas récurrents
voilà donc moi qui suis la déléguée de
la zone nord on a dance est dans cette
zone saint denis et sainte marie donc
quand on voit saint-andré saint-benoît
c'est la même scène donc alors qu'on
apporte d'autres qu'on commence à
préparer cette manifestation
alors les classes commencent à s'engager
dès le mois de novembre
donc au début de l'année scolaire donc à
partir de là elle prépare tout au long
de l'année leurs chorégraphies
et puis vient le temps des de la
confection des costumes et la dernière
ligne droite de préparation avec sur cet
événement associé pas mal de parents
justement pour les faire venir un petit
peu pour qu' il puisse aider pour la
plupart du temps à la confection des
vêtements et sur place le jour j sur
l'aide aux aux coiffures maquillage je
voudrais d'accompagnement choix de jolis
moments petite fille sur toi les
répétitions se font qu'en sur le temps
scolaire en dehors du temps scolaire le
mercredi quand essentiellement puisque
ça se passe au sein des écoles et donc
que ça concerne souvent un groupe classe
ça va se passer sur le temps scolaire
donc sur le je pense le temps le temps
un temps de ps sur sûr
sur la journée en général les directeurs
ou directrices sont d'accord pour
permettre que ça se fasse sur ce stand a
complètement complètement le la danse
fait partie d'une d'une discipline en
eps ils ont quel âge sortant quelques la
saison qu'une heure alors là cette année
on ça va partir du cp au cm2 de l'usep
ccc pour les écoles maternelles et
primaires l'année dernière on avait des
petits de maternelle qui dansent et donc
ça peut partir donc de la maternelle au
cm2 comment vous photo kl est plutôt
compliquée aux maternelles ces cinq six
ans oui 5 6 ans quelquefois quatre ans
et on a même des plus petits alors
évidemment c'est c'est c'était petite
séquence
voilà c'est des petites séquences elles
sont elles sont plus courtes pas
forcément même pour tous les petits de
maternelle oui pour les pc de maternage
pâte est pas pour les autres les plus
grandes mais pas le petit matin c'est
assez court je passe de trois minutes
pas plus que max est alors maxi pour
pencher à qu'une des corps et ça va être
six minutes on a eu des temps ce de
maternelle qui allait jusqu'à 4 minutes
donc entre le placement s'est plus c'est
peut-être un peu plus répétitif pour eux
parce que ce sont des culs des petits et
que son décor et qui doivent mémoriser
donc pas forcément beaucoup beaucoup de
gestes différents mais ça rend
extrêmement gains alors les grands je
suppose que ce sont des chorégraphies
beaucoup plus évolué et plus difficile
que les maîtresses ou d'émettre
s'arrachent les cheveux pour faire
répéter ce petit monde s'était pas de
soi pas être évident ils sont combien
peu près temps des coups dans les fonds
alors ont ils sont deux à lège durée de
22 à 30 1 30 ça sera le maximum autorisé
sur scène pour le festival dans
certaines associations d'écoles ce qui
se passe correctement quand on a un
groupe classe donc avec l'enseignant qui
peut les prendre régulièrement sur le
temps de classe et puis on a aussi
d'aider dans d'autres associations des
enfants qui viennent de toutes les
classes et donc là c'est un peu plus
compliqué de pouvoir les regrouper sur
un temps
quelquefois ça se fait entre midi et
deux sur la pause méridienne
voilà mais bon il s'est souvent vers la
fin de l'année scolaire ou là dans les
deux ou trois mois qui vont précéder le
festival qu'on met vraiment les bouchées
doubles pour pouvoir
ils ont déjà répété ensemble toi enfin
pas tous je veux dire que vous avez fait
qu on dit un filage déjà voilà alors
tous ensemble tous ceux qui vont se
rendre sur le festival demain je
rectifie puisque dans l'annoncé a été
annoncée samedi
alors c'est vendredi c'est vendredi soir
ce